Speaker 1: I am not going to do a full segment
on part two of the Elon Musk Tucker Carlson
interview.
Yesterday, we looked at part one and we looked
at a bunch of it.
There are two clips that I am compelled to
play for you, though.
Oh, this was a sack.
This is so weird.
Ellen and Tucker.
Talked about the urge to impregnate women.
As the interview really took a strange turn.
Listen to this.
I mean, the.
Speaker 2: Urge to have sex and to procreate
is after breeding and eating the most basic
urge.
How has it been subverted?
Well, it's just that in the past we could
rely upon, you know, simple limbic system
rewards of order to procreate.
But once you have birth control and, you know,
abortions and whatnot, now you now you now
you can still satisfy the Olympic instinct,
but not procreate.
So we don't we haven't yet evolved to deal
with that because this is all fairly recent
in the last 50 years or so for the for birth
control, there are some sort of worry that,
hey, civilization, you know, if we don't make
enough people to at least sustain our numbers,
perhaps increase a little bit, then civilization
is going to crumble.
Speaker 1: This this is actually I mean, this
is like wacky stuff.
And you can tell from the look on Tucker Carlson's
face that it's not even clear he really knows
the direction this is going.
There's a couple of interesting things here
because on the one hand, what Elon Musk is
saying is quite reminiscent of extreme right
wing, strict father morality, ideology when
it comes to birth control.
And one of the things that some on the right
don't like about birth control, you know,
you do hear some of them say, well, it's kind
of goes against the Bible.
You're not supposed to it's I don't even know
which parts of Scripture.
But there are some religious claims that birth
control violates the Bible.
But for a lot of these right wingers and again,
I don't think Elon Musk is a right winger
on so many different issues, but he's delving
here into a view that is very, very prominent
on the right wing.
The opposition to birth control isn't so much
religious.
It's that you shouldn't be able to engage
in what they call non procreative sex and
not have consequences.
You should suffer the strict father.
That's why we call it the strict father.
Morality would say, if you're going to engage
in sexual intercourse, there should be the
consequences of a pregnancy.
And if there is, you should be forced to carry
the baby, the baby to term.
So he's kind of falling into that, like it's
dangerous that we've separated the limbic
response from the procreation and now we have
a low birth rate.
He's kind of toying with that same stuff.
And then there's the low birth rate thing,
which has become a focus for for Elon Musk.
Speaker 2: Or question of like, well, civilization
end with a bang or a whimper.
Well, it's currently trying to end with a
whimper in adult diapers.
Yes.
Which is depressing as hell.
The most depressing.
I mean, seriously.
Yeah.
War is less depressing.
I'd rather go with a bang.
Yeah.
Your shoes on?
Not with your more exciting.
Speaker 1: There you go.
So, Tucker Carlson visibly sucking up to Elon
Musk throughout the entire interview.
All right.
They did also talk about the topic of aliens,
which was an interesting moment.
Yeah.
Speaker 2: A lot of people ask me, you know,
where are the aliens?
And I think if anyone would know about aliens
on Earth, it would probably be me.
I would think, Yeah, I'm, you know, very familiar
with space stuff and I've seen no evidence
of aliens.
So there you go.
I wish I would immediately tweet, tweet it
out.
This is.
I mean, like all time probably talk tweetable
time.
Fallon Goodies.
It's a jackpot.
Some 8 billion likes, you know, next level
jackpot if you find it.
There you go.
Speaker 1: So big reward on Twitter for whoever
announces proof of aliens and every every
aspect of this interview.
Very, very strange.
And this will certainly help to endear Elon
Musk further with the right wing community,
given the hero's welcome by Tucker Carlson.
Let's call this long two night nightmare of
the Ellen Tucker interview over, and we can
move on from there.